this is a production of cornell
university
and thanks for having me
for the seminar
um
from root to fruit so uh i'm i'm an
apple rooster creator
uh i've been
um an apple extra reader now for about
12 years i
i guess when i started i had uh very
little idea what
apple roosters wear
and
and
i had to
kind of grow up and and
come to an understanding of what they
what they wear thanks to
uh the help of of a couple other people
on our team herbalinko
and terence robinson who have been
very supportive of the program
in geneva and then here is uh jim
cummings the many of the crosses that
i'm still i'm working on were performed
by
jim cummings
he retired quite a while ago the rest of
the
rootstock team is
at least sarah bauer
and todd holleran
and i'd like to remember
charlie who passed away
a few years back um
a uh many of the trees that
we collect data today
um
were either
planted by him
uh budded by him or or
or propagated by
by him and so i um i'd like to always
recognize his contribution to the
program
um
my activity is called a cornell
i lead the appaloosa breeding program
it's a joint uh cornell and nars program
i advise graduate students i participate
in
in committees
either
local committees at the geneva stations
or other committees and then i
collaborate with the cornell scientists
and cctech to advance the implementation
of these new technologies that that we
are developing um
and
i also participate in some extension
activities and field days talks and so
on so forth as i'm asked
so those are my activities at cornell
research work however on apple restocks
requires
a lot more collaboration than
than just what we are able to do at
geneva and so we have collaborations
with washington state
usci rs in several different locations
and
and also the collaboration of the nc 140
scientists that are all over the u.s and
plus internationally
we have field trials anywhere from
south korea to south africa and
in poland
so if you can imagine all upper growing
regions um
a little bit of a historical perspective
we have released
quite a bit of germplasm uh
up to to
this day
and
this kind of tells you a little bit
where i'm coming from and and
how
uh breeding for a crop that has a
20
15 to 20 year cycle in terms of
from the time you you plant the seed to
the time you have something that is a
product
it's a it takes a little bit different
approach than than something that you
can cycle for 20 times a year
so
we
i
want to acknowledge that in 1960s the
year i was born
and robusta phi was identified as a good
parent
uh
for for that and and uh and
dr cummings retired uh right here and
then dr l winkle retired uh these past
couple years but
uh we released uh since my joining um
the the group released several root
stocks
that you'll see are having a
major effect in apple production
now here in the us and in the world so i
figured that
maybe this here we'll have
uh
for bruce ducks alone the finished trees
it's it's a to make a finished tree it
takes a couple years but we'll probably
have about uh three to four million
plants
planted
uh and and this is going to
increase
every single year
as you can see this is g41 and and it's
going up there this is g11
and um these were numbers that were
calculated in uh early 20 2013 so we
don't have the the newest numbers yet
but they're uh
the projections are are fairly good
and uh what does that mean that means
more plants that are resistant to fire
blight more plants that are replant
tolerant are going into the hands of of
growers
i recently attended a
or
presenting a seminar in illinois and and
i had a grower come back to me who was a
uh
a small uh pick your own operation and
he said
you know without without these root
stocks we would not be in business
and that's that's that that put put me
better
back in perspective of of how important
the work that that we're doing
in geneva is
so
here you see some um
maybe
there's a
hundred thousand plants in just in this
and uh we have propagation everywhere in
in oregon and
and uh now also
we have the nurseries in new york state
that participate
in propagation of geneva rootstocks
and of course
we used to have some issues with
with
uh propagation because the rootstocks
are selected for
uh performance in the field and
not as much as for performance in in the
stool beds
but as you can see here this is
propagation by cuttings someone had the
idea well you know let's do cuttings out
of these and
and uh a couple years later 800 000
plants come out every uh every season so
um i and i i'm proud of of
the nursery industry and how much they
have adopted uh our material and and
been able to work with it
and work with the kinks
so this is uh
this is our program
in uh in a uh
nutshell uh biggest words rootstocks
apple and breeding we our apples are not
good they don't taste very good but
and
susan brown teases me about that um
but i i can uh
the the good thing is that i can make
her apple trees uh produce better and
and higher quality apples
so
um
forward
so this is this is how apple production
was about a hundred years ago
uh
big ladders and
and uh
everybody had to go out and hopefully
you bring the whole family and
have sometimes
people just
falling off the ladder sometimes
and carrying big bags
and this is the way
it is it is nowadays in in some cases
the apples are placed very uh tightly
and very neatly
they calculate how much
how much a a single branch can can hold
or how many apples can
uh a single branch can hold and then
they thin to that uh
amount uh so it's pretty impressive to
see that and
that
would not have been possible without
the dwarfing effect of the apple
roosters confer so
you see this transition from big trees
to here's a big tree that doesn't have
the dwarfing jeans in the small tree
that has the dwarfing gene
you can see the effect
also in fruit
fruit density
per square centimeter of trunk
and
that made this possible which meant
less letter accidents less more
ergonomics for for picking increased
productivity
i figured that the productivity went up
about
in current
money uh 750
million uh half a million half a billion
to 750
million dollars in the u.s just based on
on the uh dwarfing effect so
um
a while back we figured out what the
dwarfing effect was uh was caused by in
our program we did we did some
quantitative genetics
and
we identify the additional locus that
that causes
the dwarfing effect and and also related
to the induction of early bearing in in
apple science
and long story short
the evaluations here
spanned about uh
i would say
seven to nine years
uh so if you're looking for a quick
paper
sorry this apple restaurants are not uh
not what you're uh looking for
but
long story short there are two loci
that interact with each other and they
affect the size of the tree
as well as the productivity of the tree
and only certain combinations of alleles
give the highest production
so
nowadays i can
go into a
marker assisted selection scheme and
select four
for
a certain combination of alleles and
predictably
develop root stocks that can produce
higher
more apples and and have a certain size
of tree
part of our
arsenal that that we developed
in this process was
a set of eqtls
that
segregated in one of our
big population one of the main
populations that we have eqtl stands for
expression qtls
and
we use the qtls in this the eqtls
in
as as
additional tools to develop markers so
we look for eqtls that are
whose apotype is in cis configuration
with the trait that we're studying
let it be
yield or
tree size or
or disease resistance and then
we find the polymorphism that is
contained in that in that gene and we
harness it
and
this is a little slide to show you a
little bit
what we're talking about so we have uh
here um powdery mildew resistance uh
that's segregating in that population
and then
several uh
genes that are
kind of associated with that uh
resistance in
in that region
and then uh we take
we take those genes
and uh
essentially transform them
into markers
that
are mapped we can we know where they are
and
they kind of look like
this when we're done with it we
we uh utilize any kind of of uh
polymorphism that we can get our hands
on so
snips or indels
endos are very nice
because you can create nice pcr primers
that amplify or not
and
that has been very useful in our
breeding program and reducing the number
of plants that that has to go in the
field
so
the question comes
to me then
we're developing these root stocks
and
and
they will eventually end up in the hands
of apple growers
and
apple growers
or orchards are an interesting place
because
well we have
interactions this is the roosters
interactions we have interactions with
the soil the ph type structure
content the biology of the soil
we have an interaction with cyan variety
that we deal with
climate temperature amount of water
that's available
diseases and insects
and then of course we have
i think perhaps the most important
interaction which is with humans
management and
i can i can vouch for the fact that
a rootstock
under different management is going to
react uh quite
quite differently and and produce a
different product
uh in the orchard so
it's it's uh it's tough for to breed for
orchard management but you know we can
try but
uh these interactions i
were
hoping that uh
our selection scheme is good enough to
be able to account for
uh the variability we see in in our root
stocks and select for the best performer
once
so
we go back to the to the basics what
does a root system do in the orchard
where it modifies three architecture
we have an interface with the soil so
root penetration anchorage soil
chemistry ph salt microbes uh competes
with our roots so you have
that
as well it collects nutrients in water
that then it sends up to the to the
scion and uh and it fights infections
survives uh in in certain climates or
thrives in other climates
so uh whenever you improve rootstock
functions you end up improving the
productivity of the tree
uh as well as i think
uh the quality of the apples that are
harvested from that tree
so
and this this is more of a general
thought that doesn't apply just to apple
roosex but it can apply to any other
tree crop or vegetable crop that uses
root stocks so there's a big push
or
with tomatoes and roost stocks
and uh and other crops uh vegetable
crops that are using rootstock so all of
these improving all these functions
through breeding can improve the overall
yield
of the plant
a few years back
we did a study with
apple rootstocks that
looked at how rootstocks were regulating
gene expression in the in the scion
or well we had the question do they
regulate gene expression it makes sense
that that that they that they do
and
then what what does the rootstock modify
in the scion
and we found out that that
in effect uh dwarfing rootstocks had
different potentials to change
the expression of certain genes
uh in the scion uh dramatically uh and
that knowledge was was important because
well all right
um
how
because it went back to how
the
rootstocks may affect
the fruit
and the production of food so
you have signals that go up and they may
be
of many different types you know here
you have ethylene but
auxin types gibberellins
water
water status is a big signal to
to the scion and then
individual
nutrients
and there are more and more things that
that the russo or the root systems can
do to affect the the scion
so
we decided that
um
we would look at
some
something that was
sort of easy to do
but
that would
take one of the these elements and
specifically the changes in nutrient
availability
we wanted to look at what
um
what does if
number one
rootstocks had an effect
or the uh
different
uh germplasm had an effect on the same
scion of uh to see if it could it would
modify the concentration of certain
nutrients
in
in the scion
and uh
um
also we want to look at how these root
stocks performed in different uh uh
solar conditions so ph water soil borne
diseases and soil type
we also
wanted to see i wanted to see if i could
mitigate food disorders that are caused
sometimes by
the lack of or the overabundance of
certain nutrients in the in the fruit
so
cal there is a very strong correlation
between calcium and bitter pit
and honey crisp and other apples that
develop bitter pit
so for from a breeding standpoint
the question was can i
select for
increase calcium availability to the
cyan so that we mitigate that problem
uh in that appears in storage facilities
around the
u.s and around the world
and
as lastly the possibility to improve on
fertilizer applications what if we could
apply
percent less phosphorus or nitrogen
to to the same planting maintaining the
same yield
uh
in
in the orchard
how would
can we can we do that and
so uh
you know this is going back to to
biology or root biology
we
said okay how are we gonna how are we
going to study this and uh of course we
in
apple roostock's
it makes sense that they they may
possess different uh
uh channels for for different nutrients
um
and here it goes into the roots uh
this is the root hair and and then the
nutrients go back up and you have the
same cyan and into the apples so you
have
so many things going on
that influence
that and i was talking uh
uh earlier and mentioning that okay
when you have a system that is so
complex
kind of had to use the black box
approach
which is
to
find out what happens at the
at the end of the
at the end of the tunnel at the end of
the process so
all of the
experiments that i'm going to show
the results i'm going to show in the
next few minutes
have a similarity
they're all grown on the same media or
treatments media treatments
and then they have we have different
root stocks
that that we're looking at so we have a
diversity whether
it is a diversity panel of rootstocks or
whether it's a structured population
where we can do some genetics
and
and then they all have the same cyan
grafted on it so that we can
kind of separate perhaps the effect of
of
individual scion properties that the
rootstocks may have
so
it's a good system and we measure
everything
on the on the common sign
so
way back then we devised
in collaboration with
dr robinson and and uh
dr craiglist who was a visiting
scientist from lithuania
we designed
a few experiments
one that would
look at ph
effects on apple root stocks the other
one that would look at
apple replant disease and
and different uh
soil types
and then
another one that
uh investigated the genetics of soil of
tree nutrition
and the actual and rude architecture
so um
and we published uh some of the results
from uh from these studies this is what
uh the experiments looked like this is
darius quickly who did
most of the
real hard work
here is looking at root systems and
washing them and and categorizing them
but these plants were grown in
randomized uh
system
and uh
in in these pots these were the original
plants before they were budded
and as you can see what a field of them
looks like and they're all individually
further irrigated
or
hand
hand fertilized
depending on the experiment this is
there were many different experiments so
um
the first experiment that uh
i'd like to talk about
is where we have two different soil
types and
sandy loam and clayroam from replant
soils
in new york state
two different treatments within the soil
steam pasteurized and unpasteurized
and
what we found was
that
both the soil and
the um
the treatment
had an effect on nutrient concentrations
in the in the leaves we harvested the
five
leaves from each replica and and so now
you're looking at at the at the means
it's interesting that
the
pasteurization treatment had an effect
on uh
final three heights of
most plants
but we and then we find
nutrients like iron
and molybdenum
kind of
being
connected somehow
to
the the tree height so how well the
plant grew
uh and to the pasteurization treatment
and then
other
elements that were
dependent more on on the type of soil
uh than uh
than the pasteurization treatment so for
example potassium it was one of the
those where in sandy soils
uh you would there was a more
concentration of potassium in the leaves
than in not
and
these were i don't know if i
they were
38 different root stocks representing
pretty much genetic diversity the
worldwide genetic diversity of apple
root stocks
and after that so you can take
all of that data and you can group root
stocks by their nutrient concentrations
and you get a graph that looks like this
where
some
are in more in the higher range and
others are really really in the low
range this is in the sandy soil
the picture looks a little bit different
in clay soil so here's another
complexity that
i didn't want to have to work with but
guess what it's there so somehow it has
to it has to
uh be incorporated into the knowledge
base
to develop
new root stocks
perhaps the answer is going
to be to
sometime in the future to be able to
develop something that is
adapted to to uh
most in most soil types in most
environments
but
my guess is that if you want to really
crank uh apples from
different a certain soil type then
perhaps you can select that you can
maximize
that
that opportunity
using germplasm that we already have
another complexity um
ph
so
we
had 33 different root stocks on and
treated the cornell mix
adjusted to different ph
ranging from 4.5 to 8.5 and
and
looked at what the effect was
of ph in general
on
onto
all these different root stocks and some
what's interesting is that some
rootstocks
here's the
phosphorus
the
phosphorus concentration in leaves uh
the root sauce were quite different in
their
curves their individual curves there is
there was a significant um
nutrient concentration by roostock
interaction
and well actually roose talks about ph
interaction
so
so that
this this becomes yet another thing that
you have to worry about when when
releasing uh apple resource because some
some proof stocks that may be well
adapted here in
low ph
soils
typical of new york state may not work
as well in
the rocky mountains or other places
where the ph is a little bit higher
and here is the
molybdenum for example
which
it shows
that the the ph treatment worked because
of the shape of the curve
overall so
um
we found also in in the in all of these
data some relationships between
nutrients that were
generalized
in among all root stocks so this is a
relationship that between copper and
phosphorus
it's pretty strong and it doesn't change
very much by
the ph
and
i could show you maybe 50 different
more grafts like this and and not all of
them are are like this some do change
but i just wanted to
uh mention that
um
this is the overall picture of of the uh
of the relationships uh between the ph
and and
actually these are all the phs put
together
and
represents the whole data set and you
can see that some relationships for
example between calcium and magnesium
are still very significant or
here you have
the one that i showed you earlier
between phosphorus and copper and so on
and so forth so
and all of these
all of these relationships
they tend to affect the final growth of
of the plant
okay
so uh
here's another complexity
and uh when you look at at an individual
ph uh treatment you can classify
uh certain root stocks or or kind of uh
group them together according to
what they what they like or
or their similarity
based on on
nutrient concentration
okay
one more experiment
uh and this
dealt with the genetics
so you have
uh so i i show you now the wider
germplasm
and now we're going into a segregating
population
we had three replicas grafted with gala
apples and
and we're now we're looking at the
qtls or qtl analysis of
this this is
the overall
status or
relationship of the
of the nutrients
within this data set and
the relationships that we saw earlier
with the ph and replant um
some of them kind of disappear but these
basically represent
uh the segregation of genes
okay this is the variability that's
caused by the segregation of genes we're
looking at in individual genotypic means
here
so um there are some things that that
are
very well connected
and they may share
the same mechanisms
and you can
summarize those relationships
by looking at
in this way so
magnesium and calcium
they seem to have very very tight
a very tight relationship that's
very pretty well known in the in the
literature
in this case phosphorus and and
potassium also share quite a bit zinc
and copper
and then the other interesting
relationship was
sulfur and manganese and what you see
right here
sodium was which is a
it's it's a it's absorbed
in i think in a very different way than
than most of these
nutrients
is is the out group or
represents a very different beast
so
take all that data and you connect it to
the to the genotypes
segregation uh
mendel's laws and and so on and so forth
and compare uh means and
uh of uh plants that have
one allele a locus versus another allele
and what we found was that
we could
find
significant effects caused by
by the segregation of alleles here this
is on chromosome 5
for potassium concentration in leaves
and
what's interesting here is uh
the dwarfing locus 1 is here but it's
not connected to to
to nutrient to potassium nutrition
because we have recombinants that that
show that
but
and then my question to you the audience
maybe you can you can tell me what uh
going from
16
uh
milligrams per gram of potassium
concentration leaves to 28 milligrams
per gram that's the
range
what does that mean to the whole plant
or the whole tree
to the fruit
so i'm still trying to figure that out
and if you have
illuminated thoughts i would mostly
welcome them but here right here you can
break down the segregation of the
individual alleles and you can see that
there is a lower alleles
combination and a higher one and then
two middle ones
good we did the same thing for for
sodium
and we found a major effect on
chromosome 17 this this
seems to
uh it's
fairly close to
the
s locust but far enough to not be it
and
again we have
uh
almost
a doubling
of the uh
amount of sodium in into into the leaves
so what does that mean to the to the
tree or to the fruit
and that's what we're trying to find out
we can find copper qtls that are that
increase or decrease copper in in in the
plants
iron
and finally the picture looks a little
bit like this
which is very complex and so
it's kind of a little bit maddening
people have seen me
walk by my office and i've got four
screens and i've got
this and i'm trying to understand what
the relationship between this and this
locus is
so more data is needed
but
the long i think the message here
is is that
we have genetic variation that we can
harness
if we want to target certain uh nutrient
concentrations
so and and and it's plenty it's there
uh and and it's heritable
another complication
so how how does nutrient concentration
relate to this
uh this is a
a
type of root morphology that is also
segregating in that same population that
we were studying
and
it doesn't we have like minor qtls
perhaps uh that that show up in on
linkage four but not much on on well a
little bit on 11.
so uh but we mapped the the uh
this uh
this morphology change
and uh
a lot of the effects are somewhat
independent of our morphology meaning
that this perhaps sits somewhere
in a different realm
of
nutrition
but
that root morphology is so important
because it shows up in
about 80 percent of our released root
stocks
so this is a typical nine
root system it doesn't branch out very
much and this is a g41 g935 here's
another one in that population g214
and uh and so
we find that that somehow this was
selected based on yield efficiency this
this this morphology
so
does this affect the
the way
fruit is produced
yeah it does um
it
how much how important is it well we're
still in the process of of evaluating
the importance of of that
um
so when you see a segregating population
when you look at at uh at
the concentration of of uh
calcium potassium magnesium and
phosphorus and trying uh try to group
and
find out different groups you can do
that and you can find
perhaps
rootstocks that have
similarities just based on the alleles
that they inherited
from from the from the two parents and
you can separate them and perhaps if you
here add the yield yield efficiency and
a few more columns you can begin to find
which rootstock has
some of these properties that that we're
looking for
um
so
right now i've mostly
spoken about um
leaves we were looking at
leaves in a scion but
heck you don't taste leaves do you well
some
i know some people do but
so uh what about fruit
and and so the next uh
iteration for for this set of
experiments was to look at fruit
and we wanted i wanted to be bold i said
oh you know we have the same population
now let's move on we have it in in the
field and let's look at what happens in
the field so this is a field in loomis
and it's it's fairly the the soil is
fairly unif uniform it's a silt loam
so we have the same population that we
were studying in in in these buckets
and uh
um
grafted with gala again
and it's replicated and we collected the
fruit and leaves for mineral analysis
i have to thank sarah bauer and and
and todd holleran for working very hard
to
with this experiment our technician
because they they work long hours
preparing the material for analysis
um
but
when when we look at fruit
concentrations okay so so we here we
look
in this orchard we looked at leaf
as well as fruit from the same tree the
fruit was collected prior to maturity so
we wanted to have
uh we want we didn't want to collect
things based on different maturities
and and we collected uh
five mature
leaves from different parts of the tree
so this is
these are overall mean genotypic means
that that we're looking at
and
what we see is that we have maintained
some relationships
uh for example this is phosphorus and
and potassium
uh improves phosphorus and food
potassium they they are in this box
right here so those relationships are
still pretty strong then there are
negative relationships
and
so you have leap magnesium and
fruit-borne that needs seem to be
inversely
related to to uh
uh these nutrients and we find a lot of
relationships now
mind you this this right here this
diversity or this
uh
is is uh
genotypic
so it's segregation of genes that's
causing this it's it's and of course
there is a little bit of air built into
it or
more more than an air that's that's why
it's not perfect but um
so we're able to perhaps select material
uh and this is the first time that we
looked at nitrogen in
both in food and leaves and we found
this interesting relationship between
three diameter
fruit
sulfur concentration of food nitrogen
concentration so
as the
trees were got bigger
we had
less nitrogen concentration in fruits
that makes sense and less sulfur
now i have no idea why sulfur and
nitrogen are are behaving in a similar
manner
perhaps some of you can can explain that
to me
but remember that that qtl that big qtl
that we found in
in leaves
of uh in potted plants in almost the
perfect environment that we could it's
not perfect it's not as perfect as as
uh as as your
the hydroponics that you do
but
um
so remember that qtl for for potassium
well
we
found it in
the in the field okay we were able to
find it in the field and there it is
in the leaves
but guess what happens in the fruit it's
gone
so
i don't know why
uh
but you can see that in the fruit this
is uh the uh
uh i think the blue are the leaves uh
right here and the uh
radar is the fruit there is very little
variation that's caused
by the alleles at this at the
potassium locus that now because we know
what gene it is we're able to mark and
and figure it out
and there is a little bit of variation
but it's still detectable and
significant
based on
on on the leaves
uh and yet
fruit uh potassium and fruit and leaf
potassium are
highly correlated so
i'm scratching my head there's there's
something else that's going on here
we do have another qtl for fruit
potassium concentration it's not located
here somewhere else in the genome
and that's a story that
will come later but but
um how does
so we and and now we're beginning to
connect last year we took uh
fruit some very rudimental fruit quality
data
simple one is was
bricks
and the pressure the mean fruit pressure
based on i think 20 fruit
uh collected from uh
each individual t tree in that
population
and uh and now we're just looking at uh
trunk diameter and and how those those
uh relation
the relationships between between these
the next stage is to increase this this
this experiment to encompass perhaps
more fruit and look at
nutrient
nutrient concentrations and storability
and
bricks and everything so we see we see
that the the rootstock at least
is having is having an effect
uh on uh on bricks and uh and the
maturity of of the of the apple
um or how soft that apple is when when
after i think it was two months of
storage
so the question is can we select
rootstocks that do a better job at
maintaining
that perhaps increasing bricks and uh
and uh
maintaining a good uh firmness
uh to to the apple yeah another
complexity but um so
what rootstocks would we choose in this
case if we
were just looking at this population as
uh as the breeder does and and we're
looking
discarding dwarfing and all of these
other uh elements
so just based on nitrogen
phosphorus potassium and magnesium
you see that they grew pretty well and
and
potassium uh potassium and phosphorus
kind of go along together for uh for for
the ride
so
we can we can do this
um but there's still a lot of questions
that need to be need to be answered in
the next five 10 15 years and depending
on whether we get the multi-million
dollar grants to uh to fund this
uh with plenty i mean if you guys have
any ideas and then
want to want to study this please i
welcome your help
but
what we have found is that
the the nutri concentrations can are
modified by
many
segregating
loci in in in a germplasm
uh tree side affects tree size that can
affect fruit
just by
just by having an effect on three sides
and where the fruit exposure is to the
sun
there is
significant rootstock by genotype soil
interaction
is it going to be the source of the
terroir for apple cider or
something like that
and the questions
what does does
nutrient deficiency have any effect on
disease resistance
perhaps
you know we have interesting data that
might show that
and then should we select for higher low
potassium
uh in in our germplasm and those are the
easy ones but we can do more
uh what genes are underneath all of all
of these and specific greens so we were
lucky to find
the potassium one because there was an
eqtl sitting right on top of our of our
potassium qtl and that was like okay
but
can we look at different uh nutrients uh
calcium can we can we increase calcium
decrease
nitrogen and so on and so forth so
we're
doing more work
uh we have uh
different science that that we've
grafted onto the the same populations
and then we're expanding this work on
different uh other population of
rootstocks
um
so
can we um
one one of the things that i didn't
quite explain is
is that the rootstock may have certain
properties in terms of absorption and
translocation but the cyan
may have its own properties its own
channels its own things and so
uh
looking at the interaction is i think is
going to be critical important
and uh
how
so
from from the perspective of of the of
the grower
how does a single gene or a couple of
genes
that affect nutrient uh absorption and
translocation
how do
how can they modify the way we manage
things in the orchard
are they going to make money
are they going to be detrimental and and
those are
all good questions
that uh need a few million dollars
so if you're uh
you know the the ride is a little bit
curvy
so i you know i try to imagine myself in
the ferrari and
i have to build it but
thank you for your time
and if you have any questions
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu
you